Pool.
- Pool.
Pool. Bist du scharf auf den Pool?
* Susanne lacht. *
* Susanne kreischt. *
In der letzten Folge von
"Auf und davon" feierte Josef Almeida
mit den Kindern in Kanada Halloween.
Ich bin für alles zuständig.
Denn wie immer zur Weihnachtszeit
verkauft Beatrice in der Schweiz
ihre Anisguetzli.
An der Nordsee übernahm Ehepaar Kunz
einen 25 Jahre alten Imbisswagen.
2.50.
Ohne einen einzigen freien Tag stehen
sie während Wochen hinter der Theke.
Auch die Oma
und die Kinder helfen mit.
Die Emmentaler erfüllen sich in
Uruguay eine lange ersehnten Wunsch.
Seit Monaten schon
leben Susanne und Ruedi Althaus
auf ihrer Baustelle.
Die Enge des Containers bereitete
v.a. Susanne zusehends Mühe.
Es ist Schlafraum, Küche,
Wohnen, Büro - alles in einem.
Da denkt man oft, dass in der
Schweiz alles viel einfacher wäre.
# Uf u dervo.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Der Sommer ist angebrochen.
Und mit ihm ist auch Che gekommen -
der reinrassige
uruguayische Cimarrón.
Che hat schon eine Freundin:
die zugelaufene Hundedame Mini -
eine Strassenmischung.
Das sind grosse Portionen.
Er hat einen grossen Bauch.
Der Clan der Schweizer
wird immer grösser.
Guten Morgen.
Warten. Warten.
So.
Der mit ausgewanderte Kater Ghöri
ist wie schon in der alten Heimat
ein eigenwilliger Einzelgänger.
* Bellen *
Zu Beginn, als er noch klein war
und ich seine Hundesprache
noch nicht so gut konnte
und er meine Sprache auch nicht ...
Da war es jeweils schwierig.
Ich hatte manchmal das Gefühl,
dass alles - das Bauen,
hier zu sein und der kleine Hund -
ein bisschen viel war.
Dann kam Mini dazu. Seither
ist alles ein bisschen einfacher.
Mini ist zwar auch ein junger Hund.
Aber sie erziehen sich gegenseitig.
* Schwungvolle Latinomusik *
Das erste Gästehaus ihrer Posada -
alles selbst gebaut -
ist bald bezugsbereit.
Bis das Ehepaar
ein eigenes Häuschen hat,
werden sie dieses bewohnen.
Was nicht passt,
wird passend gemacht.
Seit Tagen isoliert die 53-Jährige
den Bungalow - doppelwandig.
Vier weitere Gästehäuser
und ein Restaurant sind geplant.
Das ist knifflige Kleinarbeit.
Doch. Sie macht es gut.
Ja, ja.
Wir beenden das hier. Dann schauen
wir, wie wir künftig isolieren.
Sie wird immer schneller.
- Nein. Ich werde nicht schneller.
Aber vielleicht gibt es eine andere
Technik. Oder wir haben Helfer.
Dann können die isolieren.
Eintönige Arbeit hin oder her -
jeder Tag in der Pampa von Uruguay
bringt Neues und Ungewöhnliches.
* Er murmelt unverständlich. *
Das heutige Ereignis ist Flavia,
der Swimmingpool.
Extra aus Montevideo angereist
ist Poolhändler Jorge D'Avila.
(Spanisch)
Nach Feierabend können wir dann
jeweils noch in den Pool hüpfen.
Das ist gut.
Nein, es ist gut.
Es sind viele Dinge
dazwischengekommen.
Das Haus ist noch nicht fertig.
Irgendwann
muss man Prioritäten setzen.
Man kann nicht 24 Std. arbeiten
und denken:
"Ich muss möglichst bald
aus diesem Container raus."
Geht ihr baden?
Bereits angelegt haben die Emmentaler
einen Teich für ihre Tiere.
Auf der anderen Seite der Weltkugel
peitschen heftige Herbststürme
über die Nordsee.
Die alljährlichen Sturmtiefs sind da.
Doch ob Wind,
Regen oder Sonnenschein -
Sacha Kunz hat hier seinen
schönsten Arbeitsplatz gefunden.
Und die Baselbieter
haben gut gewirtschaftet.
Zeit, den Imbisswagen
ins Winterquartier zu bringen.
Für Familie Kunz
ist es das erste Mal.
Das macht nix. Das geht alles.
Nachbar André
will die Pneus aufpumpen.
Das ist übel.
Da sagte er: "Wie kam der hierher?"
Das ist so porös.
- Die sind ... Schau dir das an.
Der hier auch.
Gut möglich, dass die Reifen
nicht mehr fahrtauglich sind.
* Brummen *
* Geräusch von austretender Luft *
Das Ventil ist im Arsch.
* Blasgeräusch *
Es war so abgemacht,
dass man mit den Pneus
noch einmal
an den Stellplatz zurückfahren kann.
Dass wir dann wechseln müssen,
war mir klar.
Aber dass es so aussieht -
da sind wir überrascht.
André
hilft den Schweizern aus der Patsche.
Glücklicherweise
hat er zu Hause Ersatz.
Sowieso unterstützt er die Familie,
wann immer er kann.
Da ist ein Reifen.
Zum Glück haben wir gute Freunde.
Das ist absolut Gold wert.
Wirklich.
Ja.
Nichts
bringt die beiden aus der Ruhe.
V.a. Sacha scheint an der rauen See
seine Berufung gefunden zu haben.
* Gemütliche Version
von "Uf u dervo" *
Auch im kanadischen Tatamagouche
ist die Saison zu Ende.
Das Motel beherbergt
nur noch ein paar Dauergäste.
Ein Flügel des Balmoral Motels
ist während des Winters
sogar ganz geschlossen.
Josef ist zufrieden. Die Almeidas
hatten eine gute erste Saison.
Ich geniesse es schon ein wenig.
Alles ist etwas gemütlicher.
Ich habe zwei Gänge ...
... runtergeschaltet.
Das entspricht dem, was ich mir
vom Auswandern vorgestellt habe.
Es ist das, wo ich hinmöchte.
Zu dieser späten Jahreszeit
ist ein neuer Gast eine Seltenheit.
Hi there.
Are you a hunter?
Das ist wieder etwas
an die Heizkosten.
Das sind im Moment
meine grössten Ausgaben.
Die Schule ist aus.
Die Kinder sind aufgeregt.
Denn heute kommt die Mama heim.
Hoi.
Dada.
Sofie, André und Robin
wollen sie überraschen.
Während der Hochsaison
hatte die Familie kaum Zeit
für die eigentlich
geplanten Renovationsarbeiten.
Die im Sommer angelieferten Möbel
blieben in ihren Kartons.
Jetzt aber sind fast alle Kommoden,
Tische und Garderoben aufgebaut.
Zuerst haben wir einen Monat lang
fast keine Möbel aufgebaut.
Dann kam Papi auf die Idee,
dass wir für Mami helfen könnten.
Dann muss sie, wenn sie zurückkommt,
nicht mehr so viel machen.
Wochenlang hat Papa Josef
den Betrieb und den Familienalltag
alleine gemanagt.
Beatrice war in der Schweiz.
Ich habe Bea sehr vermisst.
Ich habe mich unvollständig gefühlt
ohne Bea.
Also wirklich.
Heute Abend kommt seine Frau,
seine grosse Liebe, endlich zurück.
Robin, kletterst du rein
und trittst das flach?
Yes!
Du bist der Plattmacher.
Ja!
* Gemütliche Version
von "Uf u dervo" *
Einmal mehr
unterstützt André die Schweizer.
Diesmal mit seinem Traktor.
Der Küstenimbiss geht heute
in seine wohlverdiente Winterpause.
Es ist etwas seltsam.
Seltsam in Sinne von ...
Jetzt haben wir erst mal Pause.
Wir können uns neu sortieren
und neue Ideen walten lassen.
Wir starten im März wieder.
Es ist seltsam.
Wir hoffen, alles geht gut.
Hoffentlich kommt er ganz an.
Ja.
So eine Jacke ist nicht schlecht.
Willst du ein Kissen unter den Arsch
haben? Ich habe welche im Auto.
Ich habe extra welche mitgenommen.
Es ist sonst zu kalt.
Autoschlüssel.
Diese Kissen
benötigen wir auf dem Traktor.
So bekommen wir
keinen kalten Hintern.
Ja. Hier wird für alles gesorgt.
* Drollige Musik *
Im Schritttempo
geht die Fahrt nach Padingbüttel.
Wir haben uns sehr gut eingelebt.
Wie man sieht, haben wir
viele Freunde, die mithelfen.
Ich bin froh, dass wir den Wagen
bei Freunden einstellen können.
Wir fühlen uns sehr wohl.
Jetzt muss der Imbisswagen
nur noch heil ankommen.
Du musst auf die Bäume aufpassen.
Die sind hier relativ tief.
Vorsicht.
Reicht.
Das wurde so zugeschnitten.
Ja, das war so zugeschnitten.
Hier geht's weiter.
Ein paar reissen wir mit.
Vorsicht.
Doch Probleme sind oft nicht dort,
wo man sie vermutet.
Vorsicht. Halt! Stopp!
Das ist nur der Tritt.
Auf diesem Hof
wird der Grillwagen bis Mitte März
seinen Winterschlaf halten.
Und auch die Jungunternehmer glauben,
eine Winterpause vor sich zu haben.
Keine Currywurst mehr, keine
Bratwurst mehr, keine Pommes mehr.
Ich glaube, es ist klar:
Wenn man es jeden Tag verkauft
und vor sich hat, ist irgendwann ...
In Uruguay
ist die Reisesaison angebrochen.
Jetzt, im Dezember,
besuchen viele Touristen
die Hafenstadt
Colonia del Sacramento.
Sie gilt als eine
der schönsten Städte Südamerikas.
* Heitere lateinamerikanische Musik *
In knapp 2 Std. erreicht man
mit der Fähre Buenos Aires.
Bei klarem Wetter
kann man sogar die Skyline
der argentinischen Hauptstadt sehen.
Wenige Kilometer
vom Städtchen entfernt
bauen unsere Schweizer Auswanderer
ihre Posada.
Ich komme hier nie wieder raus.
Trotz sommerlicher Temperaturen ...
- Soll ich dir helfen?
Ein bisschen Weihnachtsstimmung
muss sein.
Weihnachtsdeko.
Die ist fast zuvorderst.
Im Frachtcontainer
türmt sich der Emmentaler Haushalt.
Susanne will auch in Uruguay
die Bräuche,
die sie in der Schweiz
liebgewonnen hat, pflegen.
Moment.
Sie ist nicht so schwer.
Freiflug. So.
Gut?
- Hilfst du oder nicht?
Wo willst du
die Weihnachtsdeko aufhängen?
Unten.
- Aber nicht auf der Baustelle.
Doch.
- Nein. Definitiv nicht.
- Nein. Das ist eine Baustelle.
Ja. Aber die Kugeln
sind bruchsicher.
Komm schon.
- Fang mal hier oben an.
Dann kannst du immer noch runter.
- Ich hänge da unten was auf.
* Er stöhnt genervt, sie kichert. *
Ist es eine Baustelle
oder eine verdammte Weihnachtshalle?
Dort unten
wartet Susannes neues Daheim.
Ich hänge nicht viel auf.
- Schätzchen.
Schätzchen.
- Nicht viel.
Und wenn es sich löst?
- Tut es nicht.
Und wenn es kaputtgeht?
- Es geht nicht kaputt.
Es soll so richtig heimelig werden.
Ich kann es kaum erwarten,
dass wir umziehen.
Das hing zu Hause jeweils
bei der Tür.
Es kommt zur Tür.
- Okay.
Ich brauche deine Hilfe.
Du bist grösser.
Sonst brauche ich das Treppchen.
Und hier noch gleich lang.
Manchmal hat er es
nicht einfach mit mir.
Daran gewöhnt man sich
nach 30 Jahren Ehe.
Danke.
- Bitte.
Noch mehr?
* Sie lacht. *
Du willst ja nicht mehr.
- Nein.
Nein.
Che, kommst du mit?
Wir schauen uns den Pool an.
Deine neue Badewanne, Junge.
Seit Monaten leben die beiden
auf kleinstem Raum.
Das ist ein grosser Schritt,
dass der Pool schon hier ist.
Endlich hier haben.
- Man muss Prioritäten setzen.
Es wäre schön,
wenn alles schon fertig wäre.
Aber es liegt nicht alles drin.
- Ja.
Wenn es so schönes Wetter ist,
sind wir nicht im Container.
Für mich ist der Container
nicht zu eng.
Ich habe damit keine Probleme.
Aber ich habe auch
einen gewissen Vorlauf.
Ich habe zweieinhalb Jahre
im Container verbracht.
Und ...
Ich war mit Swisscoi im Kosovo.
Auch dort lebten wir
zu zweit in einem Container.
Dort habe ich gelernt,
damit umzugehen.
Meine Frau hat ab und zu
Probleme mit dem Platz.
Sie hätte gerne mehr Platz.
Sie kocht gerne. Klar.
Das rede ich nicht klein.
Das ist nachvollziehbar.
Ich begreife,
dass sie es kaum erwarten kann,
endlich in ein Häuschen zu ziehen,
in dem es mehr Platz hat.
Das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Das ist unser erster Swimmingpool.
Ja. Wir hatten noch nie einen.
Doch. Wir hatten mal ein Kunststoff-
planschbecken auf der Terrasse - Ja.
Robin.
Du kannst Nintendo spielen, wenn du
willst. Das stört mich nicht.
Noch wenige Minuten
und Beatrice ist da.
Für Josef vielleicht
die längsten Minuten seines Lebens.
Seit 23 Jahren
war er nie mehr als drei Tage
von seiner Liebsten getrennt.
Sie hat sich Spaghetti gewünscht
und Poulet.
Sie macht es mir einfach mit dem
Poulet. Das ist schon vorbereitet.
Spaghetti ... Und Sauce.
Ich weiss nicht genau,
was für eine Sauce sie möchte.
Ich hoffe,
sie hat Maggi mitgebracht.
Unseres geht langsam aus.
* Sanfte Musik *
Who's that?
Mami!
- Oh. Hoi.
Ah, ist das schön.
Hoi.
Oh, die vielen Kinder. Schön.
Hey, Charlie. Come on in.
Don't be shy.
Endlich.
Hi, Charlie.
Ich habe dich so vermisst.
Ach, meine Güte.
So schön.
* Alle sprechen durcheinander. *
Hast du Hunger?
- Ja.
Yes. Sie hat Hunger.
Ich hab's doch gesagt.
(Alle) En Guete mitenand
im Nova Scotia Land.
Willst du nicht mehr warten?
- Ich habe grossen Hunger.
So grossen Hunger?
- Ach, ist das schön.
Ich bin glücklich.
Glücklich und zufrieden.
Ich habe mich gefreut
wie ein kleines Kind -
nach dieser vielen Arbeit
herzukommen.
Der lange Flug wollte nicht enden.
Es ist das Schönste, hier zu sein.
Es ist wirklich herrlich. Es ist ...
Nice.
* Gemächliche Akkordeonmusik *
Es heisst, das Wetter an der Nordsee
kenne weder Ruhe noch Regeln.
Tatsächlich bietet die Nordsee Tag
für Tag ein neues Naturschauspiel.
Seit Mitte Juli
ohne einen einzigen freien Tag
hat das Ehepaar Kunz
Würste grilliert, Pommes frittiert,
Getränke verkauft.
Obwohl die beiden
Neulinge in diesem Gewerbe sind,
scheinen sie
umsichtig gewirtschaftet zu haben.
Hier haben wir noch Getränke.
Wir müssen
zwei Kessel Senf abschreiben.
Die müssen wir sicher abschreiben.
Das ist das einzige, was wir ...
... zu Beginn in zu grossen Mengen
eingekauft haben.
Aber zwei haben wir gebraucht,
zwei haben wir nicht gebraucht.
Bei den Bratwürsten
ging es bis am letzten Tag auf.
Wir hatten noch eine Wurst übrig.
Die hat Falco gekriegt.
Wir haben es wirklich
gar nicht schlecht gemacht.
Es gab Tage, an denen haben wir
wirklich 70 kg Pommes verkauft.
Am Wochenende
waren es teilweise 400 Currywürste.
Es war wirklich ... einiges.
Wir können zufrieden sein.
Wir durften eine super halbe Saison
erleben und alles kennenlernen.
Wir sind auf dem richtigen Weg
und haben das Richtige gemacht.
Das möchte ich nicht missen.
Den ersten Sommer
haben sie erfolgreich gemeistert.
Nun kommt ihr erster Winter.
Und noch 30 Brötchen.
* Heitere lateinamerikanische Musik *
Ja. Bravo!
* Brigitte applaudiert. *
Unglaublich.
Bei uns hätte das eine Maschine
oder ein Kran reingehoben.
Hier machen das
acht oder neun Leute.
30'000 l fasst Flavia, der Gästepool.
Damit sich die Wanne gut setzen kann,
muss binnen kurzer Zeit
möglichst viel Wasser
in den Pool fliessen.
Es kommt von Ruedis Quelle.
Der Emmentaler
checkt die Wasserpumpe.
Das muss man mal nachfüllen.
Das Wasser.
Die Pumpe läuft seit dem Vormittag
quasi ununterbrochen.
Aber das spricht für unsere Quelle.
Wenn nach all der Zeit
noch was kommt, ist die Quelle gut.
Am Tag nach Beatrices Ankunft
nimmt bei den Almeidas
alles wieder seinen gewohnten Lauf.
Die Kinder gehen zur Schule,
die Eltern arbeiten.
Bevor sie ins Motel fahren,
holen Beatrice und Josef
Brennholz aus ihrem eigenen Wald.
Die Zürcher sind Besitzer
von knapp 100 Fussballfeldern
kanadischen Bodens.
Drei Viertel davon sind Wald.
Das ist alles meins.
Unser Land geht bis hier.
Unser Land
liegt auf beiden Seiten des Flusses.
Und ...
Sie haben gefragt,
ob sie roden dürfen,
um diese Elektromasten zu sichern.
Das kommt mir natürlich gelegen.
Ich kann mich
in ein gemachtes Nest setzen.
Ich kann nur noch ernten.
Tatamagouche ist im Sommer
Ausgangspunkt
für Touren in die weite Natur.
Im Winter jedoch
ist es ruhig im 800-Seelen-Ort.
Josef nimmt Beatrice mit
auf Überraschungstour.
Schau mal.
- Meine Güte.
Du hast nicht mehr so viel Arbeit.
- Ui, nein! Das ist ja Wahnsinn.
Das hast du gut
auf den Punkt gebracht.
Okay. Toll. Mega.
Dann habe ich was zu tun.
- Deine Winterarbeit ist weg.
Ja.
- Die hat Sofie zusammengestellt.
Das hat sie gemacht?
Und du den Rest? - Ja.
Nein.
- Doch.
Langsam weiss ich wie.
Hast du auch mal ein paar Schubladen
reingetan? - Ja, ja.
Sicherheitskontrolle.
Das sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Nächster Halt: ein Gästezimmer.
Das ist die Sieben.
- Das ist unsere Sieben. Genau.
Wow!
Das ist megaschön.
Das sieht toll aus.
Oh, Mann.
Überall muss es nicht sein,
bis ganz oben. - Nein.
Habt ihr es hier wegen
dieser blöden Ausschnitte gemacht?
Ja.
Das Zimmer
ist nicht nur frisch gestrichen.
Es hat auch noch
eine Täfelung bekommen.
Das ist so heimelig.
Und dann haben sie diese
und diese Steckdose neu gemacht.
Siehst du?
Er hat mir am Telefon nur die Hälfte
erzählt. Er wollte mich überraschen.
Er hat viel gearbeitet. Meine Güte.
Er hat immer gesagt: "Ich mache
nicht so viel. Ich habe wenig Zeit."
Siehst du?
Die Almeidas sind ein perfektes Team.
Auch Beatrice
hat in der Schweiz viel gearbeitet
und mit dem Verkauf
ihrer selbstgebackenen Anisguetzli
gutes Geld verdient.
Geld, das sie investieren wollen.
Ich werde es wieder tun.
Aber nicht, weil es ohne das Geld
hier nicht laufen würde.
Es ist einfach auch ...
... mein Geschäft.
Es ist mein Geschäft.
Mein Name steht dahinter.
Es ist ein Geschäft, das gut läuft.
Und weil alles eingespielt ist,
geht es relativ einfach.
Mal schauen, ob ich nochmals
für zweieinhalb Monate gehe
oder auch kürzer -
das kann gut sein.
Das würde ich schätzen.
Es wird sicher wieder ähnlich sein.
Was machen wir mit dem Geld?
Giuseppe?
Hm.
Keine Ahnung.
Kann ich mir was wünschen?
Ein Traktor?
Eine Anzahlung an einen Traktor.
Kann ich mir aus dem Katalog
einen aussuchen?
Wir brauchen schon einen, ja.
Es gäbe da schon ein paar ...
Diesen hier. Zum Holzen
wäre so ein 5'000er super.
Der Standplatz des Küstenimbiss
ist leer.
Nach monatelangem Durcharbeiten
endlich Zeit für die Familie.
Familie Kunz
macht eine Wattwanderung.
Der Wattwurm
lebt in bis 30 cm Tiefe.
Deswegen kriege ich ihn nur,
wenn er auf dem Weg
nach oben oder unten ist.
Er hat keine Augen,
keine Nase und keine Ohren.
Das ist sein Schwanzteil.
Das ist nicht durchblutet.
Mit Wattenpeter entdecken sie
die verborgenen Schätze
des Nationalparks.
Es ist ein Unterschied,
hier oder in der Schweiz zu wohnen.
Also ...
Ja.
Es ist immer noch anders.
Es ist noch keine Routine.
Ich finde es immer noch
absolut faszinierend.
Ich hoffe,
das bleibt noch ein wenig so.
Es ist Ebbe. Bevor die Flut
schnell und lautlos wiederkommt,
kann man auf dem Meeresboden
der Nordsee spazieren.
Ein einzigartiger Lebensraum
wird durch die Ebbe freigelegt.
Die Schweiz
fehlt mir eigentlich nicht.
Äh ...
Wir haben
eine strenge Zeit hinter uns.
Wir hatten nicht so viel Zeit,
an die Schweiz zu denken.
Klar. Ich bin Schweizer.
Ich gehöre zur Schweiz.
Äh ... ja.
Es wäre gelogen zu sagen, dass
es mir gar nicht fehlt. Aber ...
Auch Tochter Noemi hat sich gut
in der neuen Heimat eingelebt -
wie auch ihr Zwillingsbruder Timo.
Die Zukunft sieht so aus,
dass wir jetzt
in den Winterschlaf gehen werden.
Es ist gut,
dass wir pausieren können.
Und ... dann folgt wieder
die Vorbereitung für den Wagen.
Und so weiter.
Von wegen Pause.
Die frische Nordseeluft inspiriert.
Sacha hat eine neue Geschäftsidee.
* Heitere lateinamerikanische Musik *
Ruedi ist ein Mann
mit grossem Gestaltungswillen.
Er ist gleichzeitig
Büezer und Planer.
Monatelang hat er
mit einem Arbeiter Gräben gezogen,
eigenhändig Wasser-
und Elektroleitungen gelegt.
Langsam nimmt die Posada,
ihr Ferienparadies, sichtbar Form an.
Bald schon wollen die Schweizer
mit dem Bau des Restaurants beginnen.
In einem Jahr
soll schliesslich Eröffnung sein.
Wenn unten eingerichtet ist,
möchten wir etwas Zeit aufwenden,
um das Ganze hier
einzurichten und vorzubereiten.
Dann können wir es als Werkstatt
nutzen und nicht nur als Lager.
Hier drüben ist dann die Wäscherei.
Das ist dann Frau Hüslis Reich -
mit Waschmaschine.
Das wird im Moment noch
als Gästezimmer genutzt.
Mein Bruder
kommt nächste Woche für einen Monat.
Er wird hier schlafen -
bis zum Umzug.
Dann kann er
den Container übernehmen.
Später sollte ein Bungalow
so aussehen: die Decke, die Wände.
Es war quasi das Musterzimmer.
Wenn Uruguayos kommen
und ich von Waschküche spreche,
schauen sie mich fragend an.
Sie begreifen nicht,
dass man eine Waschküche so baut.
Und mit jedem Etappenziel
wird die Freude immer grösser.
Pool.
- Pool.
Pool. Bist du scharf auf den Pool?
* Susanne lacht. *
* Susanne kreischt. *
Das ist ja geil.
Auch in Kanada
gehen Arbeit und Freude Hand in Hand.
Die Almeidas
besuchen ein Weihnachtsfest.
Hi.
I'm back. Hi.
- Kate.
Das zeigt wieder mal:
Wir sind angekommen.
Wir fühlen uns hier zu Hause,
in Tatamagouche.
Der Jung-Bowling-Klub hat eingeladen.
Die Almeida-Kinder
sind seit drei Monaten im Team
des Ocean Lane Youth Bowling Club.
Es gibt ein sog. Potluck Dinner.
Jeder bringt etwas zu essen mit.
Alles wird geteilt.
Wir wollen die Anisguetzli ...
... hier bekannt machen.
Schwieriges Licht.
Man sieht nicht, was es alles hat.
Guetzli. Etwas Süsses.
- Nur Guetzli?
Das ist unser erstes
oder mein erstes Weihnachtsfest
hier in Nova Scotia.
Es ist alles ein wenig anders.
Nicht so ... "frohe Weihnacht".
Nicht so still.
Es ist laut und bunt.
Noch kein Jahr ist es her,
seit die Almeidas ausgewandert sind.
Trotz heftigem Abschiedsschmerz -
die Kinder sind auf dem besten Weg,
Kanadier zu werden.
Sie sind vor uns angekommen.
- Ja, schneller.
Ja.
In der ersten Woche haben sie
schon Freunde nach Hause gebracht.
Es gibt immer neue Freunde.
Ich kenne viele noch gar nicht.
Und Freundinnen.
- Und Freundinnen, ja. Das auch.
Sie sind ... Es ist ein Glück.
Ja. Es ist so schön.
Ich glaube,
ich habe mein Glück gefunden.
Ich habe mein Glück mit dir.
Wo du bist, wo wir sind -
wir werden unser Glück immer finden.
Wir sind auf dem besten Weg dorthin.
Ich fühle mich vollständig.
Ich mich auch.
Zusammen schaffen wir alles.
So ist es.
Zusammen schaffen wir es.
- Ich habe mein Glück gefunden.
Ich habe es wirklich gefunden.
Du bist mein Glück.
Und diese drei Bengel.
- Die drei Schlingel.
Von wegen Winterpause.
Sacha will eine neue Idee umsetzen.
Man könnte sich überlegen ...
An der Nordsee sind die
Wetterverhältnisse etwas stürmisch.
Wir haben einen kleinen
Wind- und Wetterschutz im Programm.
Ja. Es ist zwischendurch
ein bisschen Wind an der Nordsee.
Ab und zu.
Gut. Super. - Gefällt es Ihnen?
- (Beide) Ja.
Sacha möchte sich einen zweiten,
kleineren Imbisswagen anschaffen.
Mit diesem wäre er wirklich mobil.
So könnte er auch im Winter
auf Märkten
und bei gutem Wetter sogar auf der
Platte Würste und Pommes verkaufen.
Mein Mann wird zum Workaholic.
Aber ja. Es tut ihm gut.
Es ist okay.
Und ...
Ja.
Wenn er auch im Winter
unbedingt arbeiten will, dann ...
Ja.
Dann soll er das.
- Wir blühen auf.
Es ist so.
Er steht schon in den Startlöchern
zur Wiedereröffnung.
Und ich bin noch ...
Gut, wir haben noch zwei Kinder,
die froh sind, dass sie uns haben.
Aber ...
Es ist mein Ziel. Ich möchte das.
Es ist ... ja.
Hm.
Es macht auch Spass.
In den dreieinhalb Monaten am Deich
haben wir
so viele Leute kennengelernt.
Es ist wirklich
ein anderes Arbeiten.
Man hat nicht den Stress,
dass man für andere arbeiten
und möglichst viel Umsatz
machen muss.
Das ist ... Es ist ...
Man muss auch Umsatz machen.
Aber anders. Für uns.
Und ... ja.
Wir haben uns diesen Wunsch erfüllt.
Einem kleinen Küstenimbiss-Imperium
steht also nichts mehr im Weg.
Danke.
- Danke schön.
Super. Ich warte auf das Angebot.
Ich schicke ...
- Ich habe die Telefonnummer.
Ja, sicher. Super. Danke schön.
- Tschüss. - Tschüss.
Für Susanne und Ruedi
ist es nur ein kurzer Fussmarsch
bis zum Río de la Plata.
Dieser ist eigentlich
der Mündungstrichter
zweier grosser Ströme Brasiliens:
des Uruguay und des Paraná.
Ins Land
habe ich mich schon vorher verliebt.
Ich habe mich schon wohlgefühlt.
Aber als ich an den Río kam, musste
ich sagen: "Es ist sensationell."
Es ist unglaublich.
Weit und gross wie das Meer,
aber noch Süsswasser.
Der Río de la Plata
ist ein beliebtes Ausflugsziel.
Es ist erst wenige Monate her,
dass die beiden aufbrachen.
Sei nicht so ein Vagant
und belle andere Hunde an.
Sie haben sich gegen die Gemütlich-
keit des Emmentals entschieden
und sich
auf ein kühnes Abenteuer eingelassen.
Es ist einfach ...
Für mich ist es Lebensqualität.
Es ist ein grosses Privileg,
dass wir das machen dürfen.
So ist das Leben so lebenswert.
Nicht meine Zehen fressen.
Nach neuen Jahren Büro ...
Obwohl ich im Büro
eine gute Zeit hatte,
in einem guten Team,
wollte ich noch mal raus.
Wenn man das so kombinieren kann ...
Ich kann noch etwas selbst machen.
Das ist Weltklasse.
Das ist super.
Seit 30 Jahren sind sie ein Paar.
Sie hatten ein Haus gebaut
und drei Kinder grossgezogen.
Mit über 50 wollten sie sich
nochmals neu erfinden.
Nur sie beide - ganz allein,
wie einst als junges Paar.
Das prägt einen,
wenn man plötzlich sieben Tage
die Woche 24 Std. zusammen ist.
Auch wenn man schon ein halbes Leben
zusammen ist. Es ist anders.
Es ist noch mal viel intensiver.
Sich an denselben Dingen
zu erfreuen ...
Ähm ...
Wenn wir im Container beim Frühstück
jeweils rausschauten
oder draussen sassen ...
Diese Weite, diese Ruhe ...
Wir können vom ganzen Projekt sagen:
"Es gehört uns."
Wir versuchen,
das hier zu erschaffen.
Das schweisst zusammen.
# U si stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für es neus Dahei.
# Si gö hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniela Zacheo - 2020